THANKS FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO MY OPEN.
YOU LIKE VENEZUELA?
DO YOU LIKE VENEZUELA?
EVER BEEN THERE?
EVER WANTED TO VACATION THERE?
NO?
GET READY.
BECAUSE THE PROGRESSIVE DEMS
HAVE THEIR WAY, SOCIALISM WILL
BE AS ALIVE AND WELL HERE AS IT
IS IN VENEZUELA.
A PLACE ONCE SITTING ON MORE OIL
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THED
WORLD WHICH AFTER YEARS OF
GOVERNMENT SPENDING AND WELFARE
PROGRAMS AND OPEN BORDERS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW SOCIALISM CAN
RUIN A NATION.
RIGHT NOW IN AMERICA THERE ARE
FORCES DUG IN, ORGANIZED AND
WELL FUNDED TO DO WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE SOCIALISM
HAPPEN.
IN 2016 BERNIE SAB DERS RAN AS A
DEMOCRAT SOCIALIST.
WE ALL WENT NO.
BUT WE FOUND OURSELVES A COUNTRY
INYOU BE DATED WITH DAs AND
PROSECUTORS, GEORGE SOROS TYPES
MORE CONCERNED WITH THE CRIMINAL
THAN THE VICTIMS.
HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL TO
EMOTIONALLY TIE YOU IN AND HIDE
THE FACT THAT NOT ALL THE MONEY
IS GOING FOR ROADS AND BRIDGES.
THIS BUILD BACK BETTER BILL WHEN
ADDED TO THE TRILLIONS SPENT ON
THE PANDEMIC WILL LITERALLY PUT
US AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF DEBT
AMERICA EVER REACHED.
JOE BIDEN SAYS IT WILL COST
ZERO.
>> WE TALK ABOUT PRICE TAGS.
IT'S ZERO PRICE TAG ON THE DEBT.
JUDGE JEANINE: I WOULDN'T RELY
ON JOE BIDEN'S MATH FOR
ANYTHING.
BUT JOE BIDEN SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING RADICAL IN THIS BILL.
>> THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS
LEGISLATION THAT'S RADICAL OR
UNREASONABLE.
JUDGE JEANINE: FOR THE FIRST
TIME BIDEN IS TELLING THE TRUTH.
IT'S NOT RADICAL BECAUSE IN ANY
SOCIALIST MIND THESE ARE KEY
ITEMS OF THE SOCIALIST COSMOS.
JOE BIDEN WHO RAN AS A MODERATE
IS REALLY A SOCIALIST.
THE BILL INCLUDES FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
SO IN ADDITION TO MEDICATION,
HOUSING, HEALTHCARE AND
EDUCATION IN GRADES K-12,
ILLEGALS WILL HAVE A FREE 2-YEAR
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
$79 BILLION FOR ENHANCED IRS
ENFORCEMENT TO CONDUCT MORE
AUDITS.
BIDEN ARGUED IT WILL CLOSE THE
TAX GAP FOR UNCOLLECTED REVENUES
AND RAISE FUND FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE'S SWEEPING FUNDING PLANS.
THIS SHOULD MAKE HUNTER BIDEN
AND
SOCIALISTS HAVE BEEN WINNING
ELECTIONS DEFEATING LONG TERM
INCUMBENTS SINCE 2016.
A GROWING NUMBER OF ADULTS IN
THE UNITED STATES HOLD A
NEGATIVE VIEW OF CAPITALISM.
TWO YEARS AGO 58% OF YOUNG
ADULTS HAD A POSITIVE VIEW OF
CAPITALISM.
SOCIALISM IS NOT ONLY ACCEPTED,
SOCIALISM ONCE WHISPERED ABOUT
IS BEING PROMOTED FROM THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
SO BACK TO VENEZUELA.
YOU PROBABLY WON'T LIKE IT
THERE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO NEED
REMINDING BE SOCIALISM DOESN'T
WORK.
THE CRUSHING POVERTY AND
VIOLENCE IN VENEZUELA IS THE
LATEST EXAMPLE.
PEOPLE GO THROUGH GARBAGE BAGS
THROUGH THE RUSH I SHALL TO TAKE
WHATEVER THEY CAN AND TRY TO
SELL THE EMPTY BAGS.
WE DON'T NEED WOMEN GIVING BIRTH
IN THE STREETS OR DYING BECAUSE
THE HOSPITALS ARE OVERCROWD OR
NONEXISTENT.
WE WORK HARD, PAY TAXES AND
BELIEVE IN CAPITALISM.
NONE OF US IS PLANNING TO MOVE
TO A SOCIALIST STATE.
IF YOU ARE THINKING OF SOCIALISM
AND YOU WANT TO VISIT VEND, BE
AWARE THE RISK OF MUG,
KIDNAPPING, AND TORTURE IS
COMMONPLACE.
THAT'S MY OPE